marlène schiappa ministre délégué auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur a dévoilé les
résultats de l'audit sur laquelle en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violences à rambouillet
vendredi 5 mars
les résultats sont encourageants ce que
nous dit cette eau dit c'est que 90 %
des victimes sont globalement satisfaite
de l'accueil
90% des victimes globalement satisfaite
c'est un chiffre encourageant important
l'équipe doit pas nous conduire à un
visibiliser les 10 % des cas pour
lesquels ça se passe mal et pour
lesquels cela peut conduire à des drames
et à la mort de ces femmes parmi les
autres résultats
75% des victimes trouvent les délais
d'attentes satisfaisant et 80% d'entre
elles ont jugé la confidentialité des
locaux est également satisfaisante par
ailleurs en zone gendarmerie
seuls 43% ont été en contact avec une
intervenante sociale au sein des locaux
de la gendarmerie
ce n'est pas suffisant c'est moins d'une
victime sur deux lorsqu'on connaît la
port et l'importance du rôle des
intervenants sociaux en commissariat et
en brigades de gendarmerie et leur
travail il est maintenant unanimement
saluée il est mieux connu c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous en renforçant
massivement les recrutements la ministre
était à rambouillet à l'invitation de
robert g député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines
le commissariat de police de la ville
n'a pas été choisie au hasard
les agents ayant pris plusieurs
initiatives pour accueillir au mieux les
victimes
l'engagement et la bonne volonté à des
policiers et des gendarmes
elles sont fondamentales c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où il ya des
engagements personnels pour créer pour
innover
on peut avancer c'est le cas par exemple
c'est avec le qr code qui a été créée et
d'initiative marlène schiappa annoncé
que cet audit sur l'accueil en
commissariats et brigades de gendarmerie
des victimes de violence serait
reconduit chaque année